JUAN WILLIAMS JUAN WILLIAMS,
DANA PERINO AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
>> WE HAVE NOT SEVEN YEARS TO
GO, FOLKS.
WE'VE GOT A LONG TIME TO GO.
>> Jesse: HE GAVE US A SNEAK
PEEK AT CPAC.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT ONLY MAKING
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
HE IS GOING TO KEEP IT GREAT
WITH ANOTHER RUN IN 2020.
TODAY WE LEARNED WHO IS GOING TO
TAKE THE HELM OF THE REELECTION
BID.
BRAD PARSCALE, NAMED AS CAMPAIGN
MANAGER.
HE WORKED WITH THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION THAT HELPED BRING
THE PRESIDENT'S CAMPAIGN TO
VICTORY AND WENT ON TO LEAD
DIGITAL STRATEGIES FOR THE RNC.
EXCITING NEWS FOR TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
DANA, THIS IS VERY EARLY,
ANNOUNCING THE REELECTION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE STRATEGY
IS?
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, GREG.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Greg: I KNOW.
BUT GO AHEAD.
>> Dana: I THINK EVERYBODY
KNOWS PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING
TO RUN AGAIN.
CPAC WASN'T THE FIRST TIME HE
HINTED AT IT.
HE KEEPS TALKING ABOUT HOW THE
MEDIA, EVEN THOUGH THEY CAN'T
STAND HIM, THEY'RE GOING TO VOTE
FOR HIM SO THEY CAN HAVE GOOD
RATINGS.
COULD'VE BEEN BEEN SOMETHING
LIKE STRUCTURALLY, HE WANTED TO
SEND A MESSAGE THING I ALREADY
HAVE MY PERSON.
STOP BUGGING ME.
STOP CALLING ME AND TELLING ME
YOU'RE GOING TO BE MY CAMPAIGN
CHAIRPERSON BECAUSE I HAVE
SOMEONE IN MIND.
GIVING BRAD THE TITLE QUIETS
THAT.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE THEIR
WORK CUT OUT FOR THEM.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC USUALLY
GIVES IT PRESIDENT A SECOND
TERM.
IT'S VERY RARE THEY DON'T.
IN OUR LIFETIMES, REALLY ONLY
JIMMY CARTER.
WELL, MY LIFETIME.
YOU USUALLY CAN GET A SECOND
TERM.
THE PATH TO THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE IS WHAT IS SO IMPORTANT.
THE POPULAR VOTE IS GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
GET.
HE DIDN'T GET IT LAST TIME, BUT
HE WAS ABLE TO GET THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
DEMOCRATS ARE INVIGORATED THAT
THEY ARE ALSO GOING TO HAVE
PROBABLY 20 CANDIDATES, MAYBE
MORE.
THAT ARE GOING TO BASICALLY
WATER IT DOWN.
WHAT'S DIFFERENT THIS TIME IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL HAVE A
RECORD TO RUN ON.
IT'S NOT JUST "I MIGHT DO THIS,
I MIGHT DO THAT."
IT IS "I HAVE DONE THESE
THINGS."
IF YOU ARE A REPUBLICAN,
CONSERVATIVE, YOU SHOULD BE
HAPPY WITH THESE THINGS.
>> Jesse: TOUGH TO DEFEND.
BETTER TO BE ON THE ATTACK.
>> Dana: THE OTHER THING IT
DOES IS ALLOWS PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO CONTINUE TO DEFINE HIMSELF
BEFORE OTHER PEOPLE DEFINE HIM.
HE CAN SPEND HIS TIME DEFINING
THOSE OTHER PEOPLE IN THE WAYS
HE DOES.
>> Jesse: GREG, YOU ARE HAPPY
HE MADE THE ANNOUNCEMENT BECAUSE
YOU WANTED FRESH NEWS.
>> Greg: THE FLAG IT TO MY
MAIN POINT, WHY HE DID THIS.
THE NAME BRAD PARSCALE IS AN
ANAGRAM FOR RED CABALS RAP.
HE'S DEFINITELY A RUSSIAN SPY.
>> Kimberly: GOT TO THE BOTTOM
OF THAT.
>> Greg: HE IS THINKING BEYOND
THE SALE.
PEOPLE ARE THINKING ABOUT
COLLUSION STUFF.
HE IS SAYING NO, WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE ELECTION.
HE IS THINKING BEYOND THE SALE.
WHEN A REAL ESTATE AGENT TAKES
YOU TO A HOUSE THAT'S A LITTLE
BIT OUT OF YOUR RANGE THAT YOU
WALK INTO ONE ROOM.
THIS IS DEFINITELY YOUR HOME
OFFICE.
THEY ARE THINKING BEYOND THE
SALE.
THEY WANT YOU TO BE IN THE HOUSE
PSYCHOLOGICALLY.
THIS IS A PERFECT BONUS ROOM FOR
YOUR POOL TABLE.
BONUS ROOMS ARE TERRIBLE BECAUSE
IT MEANS RELATIVES STAY.
DON'T GET A BONUS ROOM.
YOU JUST GET A BONUS RELATIVE.
TRYING TO LOOK BEHIND WHATEVER
PRESENT CONFLICT THERE IS, IF
YOU'RE IN A FIGHT WITH YOUR
SPOUSE, YOU START TALKING ABOUT
THE TRIP YOU'RE GOING TO GO ON
FOR YOUR ANNIVERSARY.
YOU ARE ALWAYS THINKING BEYOND
THE SALE.
THAT'S WHAT A SALESMAN DOES, TO
MOVE BEYOND.
THE THING IS, IT WORKS.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT THIS.
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN THIS
GUIDE.
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN THE
STRATEGY, HE'S GOING TO
IMPLEMENT A SOCIAL NETWORK
STRATEGY.
A CONTROVERSIAL BUT WINNING, AND
IMPORTANT.
THIS IS WHAT SALESMAN DO.
>> Jesse: HE HAS A LARGE FIELD
IN FRONT OF HIM.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A LOT OF
NAMES OUT THERE.
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT'S GOING TO
IMPACT THE REELECTION?
PROBABLY EASIER WHEN YOU ARE
RUNNING AGAINST A CROWDED FIELD.
>> Kimberly: GETS A SMART
MOVE.
DOESN'T SURPRISE ME HE DID THIS
I HEARD THEY WERE GOING TO MAKE
SOME ANNOUNCEMENT, GET THE WORD
OUT THERE.
MIDTERM ELECTIONS ARE COMING UP
IN THE SHORES OF THE BASE.
LET'S GET FIRED UP.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO, DESPITE
WHAT PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO SAY,
WANTS TO RUN FOR REELECTION.
HE'S NOT TIRED OF IT OR
FRUSTRATED.
HE WANTS TO KEEP DOING THINGS
AND HAVING ACCOMPLISHMENTS,
INCLUDING WINNING ANOTHER TERM.
THIS WAY HE CAN GO OUT AND HAVE
HIS SURROGATES, CAMPAIGN
ESSENTIALLY, FUND-RAISING,
SUPPORT THE PEOPLE THEY NEED TO
WIN REELECTION IN THE MIDTERMS
AND SHORE UP THE BASE.
TAKE SOME DISTRACTION AWAY FROM
OTHER INVESTIGATIONS.
WE ARE GOING TO GET THROUGH THIS
BECAUSE THE BOTTOM LINE IS I AM
RUNNING AND I'M GOING TO WIN
AGAIN.
>> Jesse: JUAN WILLIAMS HAD A
PROVOCATIVE PIECE THAT WAS ALL
OVER THE INTERNET THE OTHER DAY.
YOU THINK THREE PROMINENT BLACK
FEMALE DEMOCRATS CAN TAKE OUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN 2020.
>> Juan: I THINK THEY HAVE THE
CAPACITY.
OPRAH WINFREY, MICHELLE OBAMA,
THOSE TWO ARE REALLY
EXTRAORDINARY BECAUSE THEY ARE
BOTH IN THE TRUMP MODEL, AS
CELEBRITIES.
THEIR POLITICAL STANDING IS A
SUBSET OF THEIR ICONIC STANDING
IN AMERICAN SOCIETY.
KEMAL HARRIS, BIG POCKETS IN
CALIFORNIA --
KAMALA HARRIS.
YOU HAVE WOMEN AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S KRYPTONITE.
WOMEN OVERWHELMINGLY, BLACK
WOMEN, LATINO WOMEN.
43% OF WHITE WOMEN VOTED AGAINST
TRUMP.
YOU HAVE A STRONG, ICONIC FEMALE
YOU HAVE A STRONG, ICONIC FEMAL
FEMALE, I THINK THAT'S WHY TRUMP
WENT AFTER HER.
>> Greg: YOU LEFT OUT MAXINE
WATERS.
SHE'S AN ICON.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO A TREND.
>> Juan: HERE IS THE THING.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MORE
INTERESTED IN RUNNING A
PERMANENT CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S DOING.
>> Jesse: I THINK
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS ACCUSED OF
KNOWING THE EXACT SAME THING.
>> Juan: THERE IS NO
COMPARISON.
PRESIDENT OBAMA DIDN'T ANNOUNCE
THAT HE WAS RUNNING UNTIL TWO
YEARS BEFORE THE NEXT CAMPAIGN.
THIS GUY ANNOUNCED ON THE
INAUGURATION DAY.
EVERYBODY WHO WATCHED THE SHOW,
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED.
ON INAUGURATION DAY, HE FILED
PAPERS ANNOUNCING THAT HE WAS
GOING TO RUN AGAIN.
>> Jesse: OBAMA WAS RUNNING
FOR REELECTION.
>> Juan: THERE IS NO
COMPARISON.
THE SECOND THING IS WHEN YOU
LOOK AT TRUMP, HE HAS RAISED
$43 MILLION IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
THAT'S FOUR TIMES MORE THAT
OBAMA RAISED IN HIS FIRST TWO
YEARS.
YOU UNDERSTAND THIS IS A
PERMANENT CAMPAIGN.
HE GETS A KICK OUT OF RUNNING.
HE LOVES THE RALLIES.
AFTER THE NOVEMBER 16 ELECTION,
HE WAS HOLDING RALLIES.
HE HAD HIS FIRST CAMPAIGN RALLY
FOR 2020 A MONTH AFTER HE WAS
INAUGURATED.
>> Greg: YOU ARE TELLING ME
PRESIDENT OBAMA WASN'T IN LOVE
WITH CAMPAIGNING.
HE WAS AN AMAZING CAMPAIGNER AND
A TERRIBLE LEADER.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK HE WAS
>> Jesse: ONE OF THE KNOCKS ON
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS HE COULDN'T
MANAGE THE GOVERNMENT VERY WELL.
WHEN HE WASN'T ON THE BALLOT,
HIS PARTY SUFFERED.
HE WAS A GREAT ORATORY.
HE LOVED THESE SPEECHES.
THE TIMING OF THE ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> Juan: IF I WAS TO DRAW OUT
THE BOTTOM LINE, I WOULD SAY HE
LOVES CAMPAIGNING.
HE LOVES THE RALLIES.
HE IS NOT A GOVERNING GUY.
THE SECOND THING IS HOPE HICKS
WAS BEFORE THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH HOPE HICKS TALKING
TO INVESTIGATORS?
NO, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
DISTRACTION.
>> Jesse: TAKING OF
INVESTIGATIONS, DANA.
TO OPEN UP AN INVESTIGATION INTO
FISA ABUSES UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK IT'S BASICALLY
INVESTIGATION WARFARE GOING ON.
IS THIS GOING TO DO ANYTHING?
>> Dana: THE INVESTIGATION
THAT SESSIONS ORDERED WILL FALL
UNDER THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
MICHAEL HOROWITZ WHO HAS HIS
HANDS FULL.
HE'S GOT A LOT OF STUFF TO DO.
TREY GOWDY WAS ON "THE DAILY
BRIEFING" TODAY AND SAID HE
WELCOMED THIS INVESTIGATION BUT
THERE COULD BE OTHER NEEDS FOR
INVESTIGATION SUCH AS THE
STATE DEPARTMENT IN CASE THIS
INVESTIGATION THEY ARE WORKING
ON TURNS UP OTHER FUNNY
BUSINESS.
>> Jesse: HOW WAS TREY GOWDY'S
HAIR?
>> >> Dana: GOOD.
>> Greg: I BELIEVE THERE IS AN
INVESTIGATION GATE GATE.
THAT BOTHERS ME.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT ANNOUNCING
EMILY TO RUNNING FOR REELECTION
BEFORE I ACTUALLY RUN FOR MY
FIRST ELECTION.
JUST FOR THE HECK OF IT.
I WANT MY LIBRARY TO BE IN
SAN MATEO, CALIFORNIA, ACROSS
THE STREET FROM THE HIGH SCHOOL.
>> Dana: DO YOU HAVE TO KNOCK
DOWN ANYTHING?
>> Greg: YES.
THERE WILL BE FREE RIBS AND NO
BOOKS.
>> Jesse: KIMBERLY, HIS
SESSIONS LOOKING INTO THE FISA
ABUSES?
THIS HAS BOOMERANG ON THE
DEMOCRATS, IF YOU ASK ME.
WE HAVE BEEN UNMASKING THEM ALL
THAT IS ABOUT TO DROP COMMEND
THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE PRETTY
FOR A LOT OF THE OBAMA OFFICIALS
ALLEGEDLY INVOLVED.
SAMANTHA POWER, SUSAN RICE.
IS THIS GOING TO GET LOST IN THE
TEXT-MEMO INVESTIGATION
KERFUFFLE?
>> Kimberly: I THINK THEY ARE
GOING TO PAY ATTENTION TO IT.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT UP LEAD UP,
VOCAL PRESSURE.
FROM TRUMP SUPPORTERS TO EXAMINE
IT, ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE FACT
THAT DEMOCRATS STARTED IT.
THEY OPENED UP THIS CAN OF WORMS
AND MADE THESE ACCUSATIONS AND
NOW THIS IS FOLLOW-THROUGH.
FOLLOW-THROUGH EVENTUALLY LEADS
TO JUSTICE.
HE SHOULD BE DOING THIS.
HE IS DOING HIS JOB.
HE WOULD BE DERELICT IN HIS DUTY
IF HE DID NOT FOLLOW THROUGH.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS COVER IT.
>> Jesse: JUAN, LAST WORD.